questions from Shelly and Wisconsin
instead of buying a bunch of Christmas
toys that the grandchildren won't play
with we want to invest their money
invest money into their future what do
you suggest I suggest you do some of
both toys and Christmas and
grandchildren all go together in Papa
Dave's mind investing for their future
all goes together in Papa Dave's mind I
that's my grandpa name so yeah I would
do both if you want to do some investing
there's a couple of things you could do
you can do an e if the parents are not
doing any investing at all you can do an
e si an educational savings account and
you're allowed to put up to $2,000 per
year per child into that and I would put
that in a good growth stock mutual fund
and it will grow for their education it
grows tax-free for their education now
you have to name an adult as the
custodian watching over this money until
the child gets ready to go to college
you can name yourself the custodian or
you could name their parents the
custodian either one is fine either way
you should just be in communication with
the parents because all of you together
cannot put but $2,000 a year in so if
they're already doing a $2,000 ESA you
can't do another one and so you would do
a 529 or you would do something else so
be in communication with mom and dad and
you don't have to put the whole two
thousand you could do five hundred
dollars in that if you want to but I
also would buy them some toys Shelly
Christmas and toys go together it's just
part of the plan okay
and so I agree that they're not going to
use them but I'll tell you something
interesting I was doing a talk in
Phoenix last Friday to business leaders
and an illustration that I used in that
talk is not relevant to this question
but it was a Hot Wheels
from my Hot Wheels collection from 1968
now I don't remember if my grandparents
bought the hot wheels or my parents did
but I was eight years old it's kind of
cool to have an antique Hot Wheels car
in your collection I've got a bunch of
them just because I kept all my toys
that kind of stuff not all of them but a
lot of so there you go
toys are good they're not a bad thing
but I agree with you all toys this makes
Jack a dull boy but let's let's do some
investing check smart investor at Dave
Ramsey comm and you'd sit down with
smart mister Pro and they can help you
plan that out for your giving to your
grandkids for Christmas what a cool
thing to do